we
hear for the longest time the enemy was
russia right even in rocky iv
it's drago going against you know
rocky and you know everybody's looking
around the world my mother's side
they're from baku azerbaijan you know
they're from russia so
armenians who escaped the armenian
genocide come to iran my dad's a syrian
i lived in iran 10 years
so we all saw russia as the big enemy
but from my perspective and what i see
and i'm curious to know what you think
about
this it seems to me that that position
of enemy of the state or any enemy of
the world today
has been you know russia's been
dethroned today
by china it seems to me that even on the
left and the right
what they both agree on they don't agree
on a lot you saw the debate the other
day they don't agree on a lot but
if there's one thing they both agree on
the fact that neither side trusts
china more than any other country before
are you saying that russia is still a
bigger enemy to us than china is today
the russian and the chinese intelligence
services
are as different as night and day
okay the chinese intelligence service
is and has been for decades
primarily interested in economic
espionage
they want to steal trade
secrets they want to steal technical
secrets
i mean you go back you know when you and
i were young
you couldn't get a ball bearing in china
you couldn't have
get machine tools since the 1960s
chinese spies
in america have been desperately trying
to steal
technological knowledge technological
expertise trade secrets
the russians have a completely different
outlook
on how they run their espionage and
intelligence operations
i'm curious they have been interested
since the 1950s
and it's a continuous line it didn't end
when the cold war ended
in attacking our national security
agencies attacking the fbi attacking the
cia
in undermining our faith in democratic
institutions
and rubbing salt in the wounds of
american society
like race disinformation
has been one of their most powerful
weapons for example
did you ever hear that the cia killed
president kennedy
ever hear that one i've i've
read all the conspiracy theories on
kennedy and that's one of them yes
ever hear that the fbi assassinated
martin luther king yes ever hear that
aids was invented in an army germ
warfare laboratory in maryland
i have not heard that one now millions
of americans have
and believe it and you have been struck
by a kgb disinformation operation the
kgb set up a department of
disinformation in 1959.
this information is a russian word
that's informative this information is
not
propaganda disinformation is a
deliberately disguised lie
meant to afflict and affect public
opinion
and public trust propaganda is one thing
america's number one that's you know
benign propaganda what's called black
propaganda or disinformation
is a deliberately disguised and
concealed lie that undermines
your sense of reality they invented this
they're the world's greatest expert at
it
and look around you today disinformation
is damaging our democracy and that is a
triumph
of russian intelligence for a triumph of
the kgb
hood who runs russia vladimir putin
tim what what is the outcome of all
three so
if if and that's a very good way the way
you put it you said russia's economic
espionage so they simply want to be the
most powerful
other way around sorry china's economic
espionage but china's economic espionage
so their outcome is more
let's create wealth and become the most
powerful economic uh
nation in the world et cetera et cetera
china's attack russia is attacking
national secret agencies uh whether it's
cia fbi
disinformation that's what they're doing
and then usu kind of talked about the
angle of propaganda
the greatest country in the world you
know american german all this other
stuff what is the outcome of china
what is the outcome of russia and what
is the outcome of u.s in your opinion
i mean what is the desired outcome
what is the vision maybe a better award
is a vision what is the vision what
vision are they trying to
turn into reality you and i are old
enough
certainly i am to remember when
china was desperately poor
and uh in the 1970s nixon went to china
as you know and uh the desired effect
the desired outcome as you say of
nixon's
rapprochement with russia was to divide
russia and china
there was still a belief then that
russia and china were
a global monolith of communism
uh trying to overthrow american
democracy
well come to find out through good
intelligence produced by the cia
russia and china have hated each other's
guts
since the end of world war ii they were
not a modeler
so it was imperative for the chinese
to try and create wealth
to try and lift their country up from
mass starvation and poverty
which existed well into the 1970s
and one way they do this is to send
tens of thousands of students and
businessmen
into the united states and a
surprisingly
large percentage of those people who are
told
by the chinese government
and by the chinese intelligences
you need to go
steal secrets get an education we'll pay
for it
but steal what you can learn what you
can
but take what you can and bring it back
home and you will be rewarded
the russian intelligence services now
remember
the u.s only set up an intelligence
service the cia 1947
the russians have been at this since
peter the great
okay they are very very good at what
they do and they play a long game
we're not that great we're americans you
know secrecy and deception
are not our strong suits they
are very good at secrecy and deception
they send
three kinds of agents one
is the sleeper agent who comes over
lives a normal life with a fake passport
and a fake identity pretending to be
anything but a russian spy
uh the fbi investigation
called ghost stories turned into a very
popular tv series the americans
so everybody knows how that works the
sleeper agent right
then there are people posing as
diplomats
or spies right they're not the second
secretary
of the so of the russian embassy in
washington they're not
you know uh the second in command
of the russian delegation of the united
nations they're spies working for
vladimir putin
and they are attempting to recruit
americans to work for them they
have been very very good at this one of
the stories i tell him the folly in the
glory
is how the russians and the soviets
before them
cleaned america's clock going back to
the 1930s
in the 30s and the 40s and the 50s they
had spies
at the manhattan project and they stole
the secret of the atomic bomb
they had spies at the state department
they had spies at the pentagon at the
fbi
at the oss that's wartime intelligence
service that became the cia
in the 70s and 80s and 90s they had
the chief of soviet counterintelligence
at the cia
alder james was a spy for the kremlin
the head of the counterintelligence
branch of the
fbi who was in charge of spying on the
soviets
robert hansen he was working from the
kremlin
from 1979 to 2001.
they have penetrated our society and
they continue to do it today
the third kind of russian agent
is the agent of influence for example
in 1937 a united states congressman
named samuel dickstein represented the
lower east side here in new york where i
live
was chairman of the house immigration
and naturalization committee
he walked into the soviet embassy sat
down with the soviet
um ambassador united states congressman
and said i can do things for you i can
sell you fake passports
for your spies i can hold hearings
against samuel against
uh stalin's enemies here in the united
states
and he did that for three years he was
paid handsomely
the congressman was so greedy that the
kgb gave him a code name
crook he was an agent of influence and
that is the third kind
of russian spy inside the united states
and that's someone in a position of
power and authority
who can affect public opinion or public
policy
that aids russia and i submit to you
and i'm not alone in saying this now so
buckle up
president trump's national security
adviser h.r mcmaster
the former head of the cia mike hayden
the former head of the ci who succeeded
him john brennan
and the multitude of former cia and fbi
officers
that i talked to for this book agree
that the president of the united states
today the man in the white house
is an agent of influence for russia
and that is a national security
nightmare
[Music]
you